[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARIANA SARACENI: Hugh, welcome.
Thank you all for coming.
Hugh is the nation's favorite
food hero at the moment.
You are an inspiration.
You help the animals.
You help the vegetables.
You help us all.
Yes, I like that.
[APPLAUSE]
Your River Cottage cookbooks
have won you many awards,
and your "Fish Fight"
series earned you
a BAFTA and Radio
4, "The Observer,"
and Guild of Food Writers.
Congratulations on that.
Besides more than 10
cookery book series,
Hugh's work includes recent
hard-hitting campaigns,
such as "Hugh's War
on Waste," which
helped change the way
we think about the stuff
we throw away while challenging
supermarkets that definitely
need challenging, and then
the fast food restaurants
drastically in the
way they waste food.
Hugh's current mission is
to increase consumption
to expand our veg horizons,
fueled by his passion
and belief that
plant foods should
be the dominant force in our
kitchens in his new book--
that I hope you all buy, guys--
"River Cottage, Much More Veg."
He uses fruit, grains,
[INAUDIBLE],, nuts, seeds,
spices, and herbs to produce
a cornucopia of delicious,
satisfying, and
life-enhancing recipes.
Ladies and gentlemen, Hugh
Fearnley-Whittingstall.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Thank you very much.
It's lovely to be here.
MARIANA SARACENI: So, thank you
for coming to the office today.
You have quite a lot of
people coming to see you.
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
It's great.
MARIANA SARACENI: Everybody's
very excited about all the
food.
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
Yeah.
It's all about lunch really.
It's always about
lunch, isn't it.
MARIANA SARACENI: You should
also come at breakfast.
The amount of juicing
that goes on here is--
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
I hope
you haven't just had breakfast.
MARIANA SARACENI: No, no,
no, but it's good, too.
Bit of an open-ended
question to kick this off,
how did you get
to where you are?
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
Gosh.
All I can say for sure is
there was never much of a plan.
I've always sort of
fallen into doing things.
I mean, I learnt to cook
as a kid with my mom.
I was one of those restless kids
who always needed entertaining.
And if it was
raining outside, I'd
be tugging at my mom's
skirt saying, what can I do?
I'm bored.
And I think when I was
four or five years old,
she just propped me up
on a chair in the kitchen
and got me cooking.
And the first thing,
I say cooking.
I mean, I think
she produced a bag
of icing sugar,
some green coloring,
and some peppermint
essence and showed me
how to make peppermint
creams, which is basically
green, edible,
mint-flavored Play-Doh.
MARIANA SARACENI:
Organic, of course, right?
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
I doubt it very much.
We're talking kind of 1969 here.
And my mom was a keen
cook, but organic food
was a distant and not very
well-understood thing.
But I cottoned on pretty fast.
And in fact, I just learnt
I love loved cooking from
as a kid.
And I had with that
little introduction,
that little sugary
introduction to cooking,
I was very keen on making
cakes and desserts.
And I became the pastry chef for
my mom's '70s dinner parties.
And I learned to make
things like pineapple mousse
and profiteroles and
chocolate roulades and things
like that, some
of which still get
knocked up from time to time
on special occasions today.
MARIANA SARACENI:
One of my colleagues
actually, when I told
her that you were coming,
she immediately said, he has
the best meringue recipe.
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL: Ah.
Good.
That's very pleasing to hear.
Hopefully, we'll get on to
vegetables at some point.
MARIANA SARACENI: I know.
[LAUGHTER]
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
Yeah.
But I mean, those things, those
little treats are important,
too.
MARIANA SARACENI: When
she said that, I'm like,
he makes desserts?
I actually was a bit confused.
I didn't know that.
Because, to be fair, full
disclosure here for everybody,
I moved here in 2007 that
I was telling you before.
And it's when the "Fish
Fight" show was going on.
And I quite appreciated-- not
being from here, all the fishes
that I eat are obscure because
they're not in our language.
So it was quite easy
to go to a fishmonger
and just show up and
be like, I want that.
So between then, and now
your fight for vegetables,
reducing wastage,
everything, you clearly
are one of the heroes or the
pioneers of the good food
movement.
What happened in your
life, in your family,
in your eating habits
that actually you
decided, you know what, we
you do something about this?
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
That's a good question.
And moving on from my
sweet-toothed youth,
I never really planned
to become a chef.
I've been cooking
all my life, and I
enjoyed cooking at university
and with my friends.
But my plan after
I left university,
I was really interested
in wildlife conservation,
and I planned a trip
and a friend of mine.
And we went to southern
Africa for six months.
We hired a pickup truck.
We bought a pickup truck,
which we sold again
at the end of the trip.
And we drove away camping a
lot, visiting game reserves.
We took a tape recorder with
us and interviewed people
working in the world
of conservation.
And I came back to the UK
hungry to do more of that
and looking for a way
to get back to Africa,
maybe trying to come
up with a book idea.
But while I was doing
that, a friend of mine
was working as a waitress
at the River Cafe--
now celebrating this year
its 30th anniversary--
a wonderful pioneering
West London restaurant
run by two amazing women,
as I'm sure many of you
know, Ruthie Rogers and
Rose Gray, Rose very sadly
no longer with us.
But I walked in one day looking
for a job in the kitchen
or as a waiter, whatever.
And someone in the
kitchen hadn't turned up,
and they asked me if my
would stand at the pass
and help dress some
salads as they went out.
And after the lunch service
where I didn't totally
disgrace myself, they said
what do you like to do?
I said, I like making puddings.
So they asked me, they said,
can you make a lemon tart?
So as it happened, I had a
lemon tart recipe up my sleeve.
So I made a lemon tart, and
they said, that's not bad,
and we'll put that
on the menu tonight.
It's not how we make ours.
We can do that if you want
to come back tomorrow.
So I did come back
tomorrow, and I ended up
doing six months
at the River Cafe.
And I won't say I never
made it back to Africa
because I had made
it back a few times,
but that was the switch point.
But there was something about
that fascination with wildlife
and the wider
story of the planet
that I think has always
informed my interest in food
and has also allowed me
in a very lucky way--
because the TV work
that I've done--
it's allowed me to come back and
look at the conservation stroke
sustainability issues in
the business of global food.
And I mean not just global
food, but what we all
choose to eat every day
is part of that story.
What we are choosing
to eat on a daily basis
is probably affecting the planet
more than any other decisions
being made by human beings.
I mean, we do extremely
things on this planet.
We make extraordinary buildings.
We build amazing
electronic gadgetry
and we program it in
brilliant and innovative ways.
And that, of course,
affects the world,
but probably nothing
affects the world more
than the way we produce food.
It's the main reason we're
chopping down forests,
which arguably-- well, in
my view, not arguably--
we need to keep.
We're doing all
sorts of things often
in the name of feeding the
world that could ultimately
jeopardize feeding the world.
Because, if we don't look after
the primary resources of--
I'm going off on
one now, aren't I--
the primary resources
of a planet.
MARIANA SARACENI: I want
to be like, stop it.
Everybody, veg.
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
Well, exactly.
I mean, if we don't look
after those primary resources
in a sustainable way, we will
run out of stuff to grow food
on and we'll be in trouble.
But the great thing,
the exciting thing,
is that we can cook and eat
our way out of this problem
by changing the decisions
and the choices that we make.
Many, many things are
happening in the world
that make those changes
really, really hard.
We are hugely
under the influence
of the industrial
food machine, and it
wants us to behave
in certain ways
because it's highly
profitable if we do.
And what it's become
incredibly good at--
I really am going
off on one now--
what it's become incredibly good
is molding very inexpensive,
highly-subsidized,
highly-refined ingredients,
essentially sugar, cheap
vegetable and animal fats,
and highly-refined starches--
wheat flour is a lot
of it, but increasingly
soya starch and
things like that--
just respinning them into
endless different products
and putting little bits
and sprinkles on that
actually make them incredibly
difficult to resist.
It's pretty much
an exact science
making inexpensive food
very hard to resist
and creaming off
a lot of profit.
And that's taking us
away from the sort
of bounty of natural
foods that really
should underpin our diet.
And essentially, that's
unrefined plant foods.
That's what we need to put back
at the center of our eating.
Doesn't mean we have to
be vegetarian or vegan.
I'm neither of those things.
I eat meat and fish.
But I eat meat and
fish carefully, I hope.
And to eat any of those
things without thought
is potentially contributing
to the problem.
To make your food choices
in a thoughtful way
is contributing to the solution.
MARIANA SARACENI:
That's actually
a perfect opening to my next
question because I've been--
Netflix, there's five
million food documentaries,
and I just love watching
everything food related.
And I've been
watching quite a lot
of vegan and plant-based
documentaries.
And both views tend to
be very black and white.
Either you eat meat or
you never eat meat at all.
One of them actually was
the most generous one saying
it will not be sustainable.
If the entire
planet wants to eat
organic plant-based food 100%,
it will not be sustainable.
You do not have
to be 100% vegan.
You just need to be very
mindful of what you eat.
I was just telling
you before I currently
have in my diet two
vegetarian days a week,
and I'm trying to incorporate
a vegan one, which I really
hope you help me
because I'm struggling
without the cheese
and the butter.
But how do you think
we should approach
this in terms of quantities?
Not only having the animals as a
side dish rather than the main,
how do you think people
should approach this?
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
I think
there are many different
ways to approach it.
And I mean, it is
interesting to me
that more and more
people and young people
are making the
choice to be vegan.
And I think it's a great choice.
I mean, because I've written
enthusiastically about meats--
one of my early books was
"The River Cottage Meat Book,"
and I've cooked meat
and fish in the shows--
other chefs have put
themselves out there somehow
being critical of
vegetarianism or veganism.
And maybe sometimes people have
assumed that I'm in that camp.
I think it's great that more
and more young people are
choosing to be vegan.
I've got time for anyone
with principles about food.
Anybody who's thinking
about what they eat
and thinking about the
consequences of the choices
they're making, I
think that's fantastic.
And if more and more
people on the planet
become vegan and
vegetarian, that's
going to help the situation.
I do think there are
ways to incorporate
fish and meat into your diet.
I think both foods can be
very healthy if well-chosen.
And they can be sustainable--
again, if carefully chosen.
But the thing that's really
difficult and damaging
is this idea that was
born of the great miracle
of industrial farming of
industrial meat production,
that somehow no meal is
complete without meat--
somehow, two or even
three times a day.
The old, great,
British breakfast fry
up once in a while, twice a
year maybe, fantastic thing.
But I mean, if
you're going to have
sausages and bacon for breakfast
and a beef sandwich at lunch
and then more meat or
fish in the evening,
if we're all doing that,
there's no way we're not
in trouble as a planet.
So we've really got
to balance things out.
And I think meat and fish
can be incredibly delicious.
If you put a little bit
of fierce heat on them
and you sear that
edge of the steak
or the crispy skin
or the fish, you
create a really special flavor.
And I get that.
And that's something
we can enjoy.
And also in moderation,
those foods are very healthy.
They've got great proteins
in them, good amino acids.
They're good, digestible foods.
So that's kind of where I'm at.
But to recklessly consume them
the sort of commodity foods
is a big part of
the problems that
are stacking up that we're going
to have to solve in the years
ahead.
MARIANA SARACENI:
Very much agree.
In terms of now jumping
into vegetable specific,
your mother--
you come from a
gardener family, so you
have an unfair advantage
because in my family nobody
has a green thumb.
So in terms of growing, I've
tried and failed miserably.
I even signed up and paid for
an allotment that is just now
flowers because I have no clue.
Do you have any tips
for us Londoners
living in the typical,
non-outer-space London
apartment?
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
Yeah.
I mean, I think if you've
got any space at all--
and it doesn't even have
to be outdoor space-- where
you can put a pot with soil
in it, I mean, lots of people
are in the house plants.
I think why not grow
edible house plants.
I mean, that just
makes me more excited
the fact that at
the end of it I'm
going to get some
food out of it.
It might just be a window box
full of herbs or one big pot
with a tomato plant
growing in a sunny window.
Anything like that,
anything that you've
grown yourself is always going
to taste fantastic and just
remind you--
not necessarily consciously,
but subliminally--
that this stuff
comes from the soil.
We can take a bit of soil.
We can look after
our own bit of soil,
and we can grow
some food from it.
And we're connected
to the whole process.
to the problem.
We're connected to the solution.
We're part of it.
I mean, obviously, if you can
find an allotment in London
and get a bit busy, people
get really excited about that.
And once you start
doing a bit of that,
from the people I talk to,
people tend not to backslide.
Once you start growing
a little bit of food,
it's a pleasure that
becomes part of your life
and you tend to want
to do more and more.
MARIANA SARACENI: Is there
like a super-easy one, one
of the vegetables or
spices you can be like,
you really can't mess this up?
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
Well, lots of things
are much easier than
you think, but I
think the really
important thing is
to choose something that you
will then really look forward
to eating.
There's no point in growing
a vegetable that you're not
enthusiastic about, maybe
just because it looks cool.
Very easy to grow
a courgette plant
on a balcony or a window sill.
A fun thing to do is to
grow things in a window box
and direct them that way
and then let them climb up
a trellis and harvest
them on the floor above.
You know, there's all
sort of fun you can have.
MARIANA SARACENI: Talk to
your neighbors first, please.
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
Climbing beans and peas
are easy to grow.
Herbs, obviously, really
useful because you
can use a bit of them every
day or a few times a week.
Just grow something that you're
going to get excited about.
MARIANA SARACENI: Beautiful.
Besides growing, any tips
for buying vegetables
in the supermarket.
Farmers' market I'm
hoping are ideal,
but if there's no
close-by farmers'
market, tips from buying
vegetables in supermarkets?
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
I think
that the ideal when
buying any food
is to know as much about
it as you possibly can,
to know the story of
where it comes from.
For me, it's that connection.
I've talked in the past about
the idea of a sort of continuum
which I've sort of glibly called
the food acquisition continuum,
or FAC for short.
Which is, basically,
we're all somewhere on it.
And at one end of it,
over here if you like,
there are millions of us now
who are almost completely
dependent on made
food-- essentially,
industrially-produced food.
Ready meals and takeaways,
that's what we eat.
We don't cook.
We don't even buy
ingredients, and we're
at this end of the scale.
Right down at the other
end of the scale--
and there's not
many of the people
on the planet left doing this--
you've still got a
few Kalahari Bushman,
a few Amazonian tribes who are
essentially hunter-gatherers
who wake up in the morning
and the only real issue
is to feed themselves
and their extended family
and the others in
their tribe, and they
have an extraordinary range
of seasonal knowledge.
And as far as they may have
been left some land that they
can still explore, historical
and tribal and seasonal
knowledge and the
different value
of plants at different
times of year, and they
may still hunt and fish.
Not many of them left, as I
say, but we're all somewhere
on that continuum.
And my whole contention, the
whole River Cottage argument,
if you like, from the very
beginning has been it's
really good to get a little bit
further down towards some kind
of self-sufficiency,
some closer connection
to the origins of your food.
And you can do it by,
just as we talked about,
growing food in
whatever environment
you find yourself in.
But you could also do it
in the way that you shop.
And that means buying
less anonymous food
and more food where,
as you buy it,
you get a little
bit of the story.
You get a bit of the context.
So that's why farmers'
markets and all markets
have got a lot going for them
because you've got somebody
there who's selling with passion
something that they believe in.
Maybe they've made
it themselves.
Maybe they've grown
The idea of farmers'
market really
is they should only
be staffed by people
who are connected
from the farm itself
so they can really tell
you the story of that food.
I get that that's not
easy for everybody,
but it does make
shopping a real pleasure
in itself and the cooking
thereafter because you're
taking with you back into
your kitchen some of the story
and some of the understanding
and some of the connection
with that ingredient.
It's kind of mindful.
It puts your mind in a better
place than if you're cooking
sort of cling-wrapped, anonymous
food from the supermarket
and you couldn't even say
which country came from--
sometimes, if it's meat,
which animal or animals.
There's so much you don't know.
I find it scary to be
presented with food that I
don't know anything
about, and my basic rule
is I don't eat it.
MARIANA SARACENI:
That's a good policy.
And now, moving
specifically to this book,
I have to say this is
going to sound very random,
but I already told you
about this I seriously
have love and respect for
you for the swaps option
that you put.
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
The swaps?
MARIANA SARACENI: Yes.
I am very much like yes, free
spirit, everything's great.
But when it comes to
a recipe, either I
don't follow a recipe or
I follow a recipe to a t.
So if it says 336 milliliters
of [INTERPOSING VOICES],,
I really get very if
I don't have that.
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
Precision
is rarely vital in cookery.
MARIANA SARACENI: I agree.
Still, I know it's my issue.
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
As a pastry chef,
as a former pastry
chef-- well, not former,
I still make some
nice desserts--
but, yeah, if you're making
a cake, you need to be there
or thereabouts.
But even then, there's
probably a little bit more
give the most people think.
But for this kind of
cooking and for the kind
of nice, rich, tasty assemblies
of different ingredients,
you don't need precise
amounts of anything.
Maybe be a little bit
sharp with your seasonings.
Otherwise, you can relax.
And what I've done
in several books now
is I've suggested
a bunch of swaps.
I mean, there's no reason at all
why a carrot recipe won't work
brilliantly with celeriac
or parsnips or another root
vegetable.
It won't be the same, but that
would be part of the joy of it.
It will be exciting
and delicious.
So I've suggested a few
swaps, but the idea really
is make your own swaps.
Do you think, well, I haven't
got that, but I've got this,
will it work?
Of course it'll work.
MARIANA SARACENI: Oddly enough,
I understand what you mean,
and it makes sense.
But in my crazy
mind, I kind of like
needed you, the person who wrote
the book, to tell me it's OK.
Go ahead.
I feel kind of validated.
Like, OK, I'll play with it.
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
It is OK.
Go ahead.
MARIANA SARACENI: Thank you.
So considering this is not
your first vegetable cookbook,
how do you come to do recipes?
Do you decide and
say, you know what?
Today, I'm going to
explore carrots or today
I'm going to explore--
I don't know-- buckwheat?
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
The first thing,
and I'm not too shy
about admitting this,
is it's a highly-collaborative
business for me,
and I work very closely
with two amazing people.
One of them used to be my
head chef at River Cottage,
the Cookery School, Gil Meller.
He's just written a
beautiful cookery book
himself called "Gather,"
his first solo cookery
book, which has rightly
won loads of awards--
very much in the spirit of
what we do at River Cottage,
foods of friends
gathered from close by.
So he's my sounding
board for recipes.
And I've also been working with
my food editor, Nikki Duffy,
for more than 10 years.
So Gil, Nikki, and I are a team,
and we get together regularly
and we brainstorm
ideas for a book.
And we go away, and we
cook different things
and we send each other pictures.
And we get together
again and have tastings
and swap things around.
And that's how we do it.
First couple of
books I wrote were,
I literally kind
of sat in a garret
and did them all on my own--
the original "River Cottage
Cookbook" and the meat book.
But since I've been
working with Gil,
he's so talented it
just seems natural to me
to swap ideas with him.
So we've got a
pretty good system,
and the recipes only make it if
we all think they're damn fine.
And I love having them alongside
me to help make it all happen.
MARIANA SARACENI: Do you
guys test your recipes
on your families?
As in, kind of like, if my
mother-in-law passes a test?
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
Yes, we do.
They don't stay just inside
that collaborative circle.
We have various people.
My sister does quite a lot
of tasting and testing.
Some of the team down
at River Cottage--
not just the kitchen team
because it's really important
that your recipes are tested by
people who are not in any way
professional cooks
because professional cooks
won't read the recipe anyway.
They'll do what they want.
So yeah we have
a bunch of people
who help us out with that.
MARIANA SARACENI:
Including kids?
Because that's another
thing, I have three nephews,
and it's quite challenging to
get them to eat a vegetable
unless you make a story of
the magic of the tomato.
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
Yeah.
I mean, I don't
necessarily put kids
in charge of recipe
testing, but I'm
very happy for them
to get involved.
And my recipes are being
tested in a family kitchen,
and hopefully they are
passing the kid test
at some level or other.
MARIANA SARACENI: Great.
If you could pick one or
three favorite recipes
from this book, which
ones would they be?
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
That's so, so hard.
I think what I'd like to say
about the recipes generally is
that what's so important that
we recognize about vegetables--
and indeed, we should really
say plants because as you
mentioned, of course the whole
spectrum includes fruits,
seeds, spices, nuts,
grains, and pulses,
as well as the things that we
think of in an everyday sense
as vegetables--
we have to recognize there's
an extraordinary palette
of different
textures and flavors.
Compared to meat and fish, it's
an amazingly-rich, broad world
of flavors.
We're so hidebound and so
dominated by meat and fish
in our diets that
we've hardly begun
to scratch the surface of
the sheer possibilities,
the infinite
possibilities of combining
all the different plant
foods in delicious ways.
So the first thing
I've done in this book,
even more than in
the last one, is
to sort of throw out the
rulebook and just try things.
So there's loads of
recipes where I mix
fruit and vegetables together.
One of the things I'm
doing a lot at the moment
is just, because
I've got tomatoes
in the greenhouse and plums
just coming to an end,
there's a tomato and
plum salad in there.
And just the two
different flavors--
I mean, they're both
fruits, obviously,
even though we think of
tomatoes as vegetables--
but just the tart
sweetness of one
and the tart
sweetness of another,
yet aromatically they're
completely different.
As it happens, They go
really well together
with a little bit
of aniseed herb,
like a bit of basil or
torn tarragon in there.
You get an extraordinary
combination
of different flavors.
It's really exciting.
So there have been lots
of experiments there.
And the recipes
there, I suppose--
and I think, is it
on the menu today?
There's another roast
beetroot, plum, and tomato.
MARIANA SARACENI:
Is it on the menu?
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
It's out there.
MARIANA SARACENI: Yes, it is.
Go eat it, everyone.
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
It takes those two flavors
and intensifies them through
roasting and combines them
with another thing, which
is a root vegetable.
And again, it's a
really beautiful, deep,
resonant spectrum of
flavors that you get.
So really, it's been about
having fun with that.
And the other thing, of
course, is technique.
And when I say that, I don't
mean in a difficult way.
When it comes to
fish, you know we've
got the barbecue, the
oven, the frying pan.
And yet, for so long,
vegetables seemed
to be either boiled
or raw in a salad.
Let's roast more vegetables.
You'd really
challenge me to think
of a vegetable that is
inappropriate at any time
to roast.
There's a recipe for
roast lettuce hearts
in the book where,
in a hot oven,
you caramelize
those cut corners.
Those little burn
brown bits that you
get on the edges of
your roast roots,
you can do that
with cauliflower.
You can do that with broccoli.
You can do that with lettuce.
You can do it with leeks.
You can do it with
all kinds of things.
MARIANA SARACENI: The
latest thing I'll try.
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
Does that
let me off answering the what's
your favorite recipe question?
The squash patties, which
are on the menu, that's
a little comfort.
Again, you've made
something there,
it's kind of a little
bit like a veggie burger,
but you've surrounded it with
a few little seeds as well.
And you've got some chickpea
in there and some squash,
so it's got that satisfying,
slightly-carby comfort food
thing but with some
seeds and spices
just to give it a
little bit of edge.
And I think that's as satisfying
as any kind of fried thing.
MARIANA SARACENI: Beautiful.
I have a list of now kind
of like quickfire questions,
which are very much
like one or the other.
Don't get nervous.
It's fine.
Is there any vegetable
that you think
isn't worth the while, one
that you think, you know what?
No.
Or one that you just
simply don't like?
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
Any vegetables
that are not worthwhile at all?
MARIANA SARACENI: Don't be shy.
We all have something
we don't like.
HUGH
FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL: God.
I'm just trying to think.
AUDIENCE: Baby sweetcorn.
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
What's that?
AUDIENCE: Baby sweetcorn
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
Baby sweetcorn.
Yeah.
MARIANA SARACENI:
That's very random.
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
Yeah.
MARIANA SARACENI: You
can't steal her answer, no.
[LAUGHTER]
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
Thank you
for coming to my rescue.
It's true that I can't get super
excited about baby sweetcorn.
But even then, I don't hate it.
I don't hate it.
Actually, I find
bell peppers not
super exciting on their own.
There's a nice kind
of sweetness there,
but I think they really
come into their own
when they're roasted and
cooked and caramelized
and blended with other things.
And I always think that
thing of a salad that's
got slices of green pepper and
slices of onion, of raw onion,
you've got harsh flavors
that aren't being
sort of mollified or blended.
It's that salad that is
lettuce, cucumber, peppers,
and raw onions.
It's like, those they're
all four great ingredients,
but they don't
necessarily just work
if you plop them raw on
the side of the plate.
MARIANA SARACENI: It's
like a plain salad.
Or you say, like something,
a plane that flies.
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
I mean, I'd rather just
have the lettuce with a nice
dressing or roast the peppers
and the onions
together or break them
down really small
into a salsa so you've
got finely-chopped onion working
with a finely-chopped pepper.
And then maybe add some seeds
and spices and just kind of--
MARIANA SARACENI: Yeah.
I hear you.
Bell peppers on their
own are impressive.
For the next question, you
cannot say something like
Italian.
Three favorite
foods, items of food.
For example, I could
not live without them
without tomatoes,
lemon, and rice.
I would literally just give
up anything except those three
things.
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL: OK.
This is really good that
you've got your mind made up
about this stuff.
[LAUGHTER]
MARIANA SARACENI:
Are you kidding me?
I have my death row meal
plan and everything.
And I ask everybody
that I work with,
even clients in interviews.
The first thing I ask, before
we talk about anything, what
are your three favorite foods?
I need know what I'm
up against, guys.
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
Shall
we say three
favorite vegetables?
MARIANA SARACENI: I leave
that poetic license to you.
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
There
are three things that
I think kind of we
don't explore or do enough with.
And I say one of
these as someone
who used to be quite rude
about this vegetable,
but I've really come
around to cauliflower.
And I've come around
to it by virtue
of doing things
like barbecuing it
or cutting it into thin
slices and putting it
in a really hot pan and getting
a little bit of color on it
and then dressing it
with some oil and seeds.
Or, it makes a wonderful soup.
So cauliflower, let's talk
about the under-rated.
Celeriac is another
one, which looks
like a big, weird, curly
lump that you would struggle
to get really
enthusiastic about,
but it's incredibly aromatic.
And it's got so many qualities.
And also, it's different.
If you shave it in very thin
slices, that's one thing.
You can spread it
out and dress it raw.
Matchsticks raw is another.
But then, cooked,
roasted again in cubes.
Or, one of my
favorites, a mash of
half celeriac and half potato
is really, really beautiful.
MARIANA SARACENI: Jason
does it often here.
Seriously, it's like
a mash of things.
Jason is our chef over there.
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
Or a celeriac gratin,
thinly-sliced chilis.
Obviously, old school, you
would put a bit of cream in,
but we don't necessarily
need to go there.
I mean, that's the other thing.
This book is vegan.
It's not written
just for vegans.
It's written for everybody.
And so the last veg book
was vegetarian but included
cheese and dairy and all sorts.
But I wanted to take
this to another level
just really to prove the point
that I've been banging on about
since I got here
really, which is just
extraordinary under-explored
world of these vegetables
where you don't need
the cheese on top.
Of course, it's fine
and cool to put,
and there's loads
of lovely recipes
that combine vegetables with
dairy and vegetables with meat.
But I just want to celebrate
vegetables in and of themselves
and the amazing things
you can do with them.
Then, if you want to
add something on top
or put it on the side or
serve any of these recipes
next to a simply-cooked
piece of fish,
I've got no problem with that.
But right here, right now,
it's all about the veg.
MARIANA SARACENI: To
be fair, we actually
are very blessed here
at Google, and we
have such a plethora of foods.
The vegan days are
much, much easier
because you guys give me
such great vegan options.
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
Because you have really
talented chefs here, and I've
met some of them already.
And that's fantastic.
For an organization
in their workplace
to be able to offer
really seriously
well-thought-out
food that includes
a really exciting attitude
to vegetables is very cool,
but it is quite unusual.
MARIANA SARACENI: It is
unusual, but I do love it.
Thank you, guys.
[APPLAUSE]
I have two questions left before
we move to all of you guys
being able to ask questions.
Your thoughts on use-by
date or best-before dates,
sell-by dates?
Do you think they
are a suggestion
or you should follow them?
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL: Of
course they are a suggestion.
You know, used by I've
got a bit of a problem
with because it's
quite a bossy thing.
It's like suggesting you've
really got to do this thing.
And I think a lot of
people-- and I didn't really
realize this-- but when
we did the waste series,
I talked to people.
They actually felt
really compelled.
I thought the
spinach looked fine,
but it said used by
the 11th of March.
So on the 11th of March
on the 10th of March even,
I had to bin it.
You really don't have to.
The first thing to care
about is cooking foods.
If a vegetable is
a little bit tired,
you might not want
to eat them raw,
but you can roast them
or make them into soup
or put them together with
various other things.
There's no real safety
issue of anything
that's properly cooked.
Anything that's heated above
70 degrees for three minutes
is safe.
But I have to say
one or two things,
very few toxins
that don't survive--
toxins not bacteria.
All bacteriological
contamination
is killed at 70 degrees
for a couple of minutes.
No doubt about that at all.
There's a few rather
unusual toxins
that can appear in things
like fermented rice
that has gone off
or beans that you
have to be a little bit careful,
but that's a bit out there.
Mostly, heating food
makes it really safe.
So there's no really
real safety issue.
So if it looks OK and it
tastes OK, what is the problem?
MARIANA SARACENI: Back
home, we actually don't even
use it as a suggestion.
We just use it as
a marketing lie.
So when I moved here with
a bunch of British people--
my husband is French--
they were all outraged that
I never checked anything.
I just smell things.
And they're like, what
if you have a cold?
I'm like, I might get sick.
We'll see.
I don't know.
Look at it.
It's melted.
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
You've
been equipped with pretty
good sensory apparatus
for telling you whether
food is OK to eat or not.
And we don't want to be
disassociated from that.
It's important that we know how
to use those physical tools.
MARIANA SARACENI: I don't
know if your friend replied
to your message, but
in London restaurants,
besides the full-on
vegetarian or vegan
ones, somebody that's doing
a great job at vegetables?
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
Aside from or including?
MARIANA SARACENI: No, aside.
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL: OK
MARIANA SARACENI: One that
actually could be serving meat,
but they are very good
putting the [? hero ?] part
of vegetables on the plate.
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
Yeah.
I'm not great at keeping up with
the London restaurant scene.
I tend to go back to
old favorites including,
from time to time, the River
Cafe where I used to work.
It's always taken
their vegetables very,
very seriously along with
their pasta and, of course,
their fish and meat.
But I am going to mention one
place because a friend of mine
took me to a place called
Sunny's Olive Tree, which
is a vegan takeaway
in Cowcross Market.
I'm very bad.
Does anyone know where that is?
And it was so much
in the spirit--
it was just beautifully
simple, a few salads,
a few cooked things
piled up together,
lots of brilliant flavors.
And the key was going
halfway down the street.
And I just took that as
massive encouragement.
And any restaurant that isn't
taking vegetables seriously--
and I'm doing a piece
of work for a TV series
at the moment where
we are going to be,
at the opposite end
of your question,
highlighting a few well-known
chains who particularly don't
take the responsibility of
feeding vegetables to kids
nearly seriously enough.
Because it's really important
to get young diners for whom
going out to eat a meal with
their family is such a treat.
To encourage them to think
from the age of five or six
that the world of
eating out only
consists of carbs, fish, and
meat is dangerous behavior.
So we've got to look at that.
MARIANA SARACENI: Very
exciting about that
because I'm actually against
kids mainly using restaurants.
I think kids should eat the
same thing as adults, just
smaller portion.
So the same vegetables
that I should eat,
kids should eat them.
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
Well, I think, broadly
speaking, I agree
with you, but I
think that lots of
families going out
do like a little bit
of help, but they're
getting the wrong kind of
help a lot of the moment.
MARIANA SARACENI:
Because you're just
being led by the
restaurant saying,
oh, this is kid friendly, and
then they just [INAUDIBLE]..
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
Would they
like chips with their pizza?
They'll be happy.
MARIANA SARACENI: I agree.
So guys, if anybody wants
to come and ask Hugh any
questions-- or myself,
I'm open as well--
there's a yellow
mic in the middle.
Please go ahead.
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
It's an open-mic slot.
AUDIENCE: Two quick questions.
Which international cuisine
excites you the most,
and who's your favorite TV
chef apart from yourself?
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
Well, I hope it isn't me.
International, it's
so hard because I
think one of the great
things about this country
is the amazing access we
have to some of the best food
from all around the world.
But I'd never actually been
to India until four years ago,
and I went there.
I took a family sabbatical.
I took time out, four months,
and it was an incredible trip.
And we based ourselves
in Delhi and went and did
various different
trips from there.
And I had some incredible food,
and it really opened my eyes.
And that influence has found
its way into this book.
So probably India.
Sorry.
What was the other question?
AUDIENCE: Favorite TV chef?
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
Well,
no longer with us, but
Keith Floyd, what a legend,
what a legend.
And I'm sure I wouldn't
be sitting here today
if I hadn't been glued to
Keith Floyd as a student.
And what he did that I
think was incredible--
and I hope I've lived
up to it in some ways--
is he took food
out of the studio
and went to find out
where it was coming from.
And he met food
producers and celebrated
what they were doing and
went out on a fishing boats
and cooked in the galley
and that kind of stuff.
And the energy around
that and the excitement
about provenance and food
has always stayed with me.
MARIANA SARACENI: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Hugh.
Thanks so much for joining us.
Such an interesting chat.
My question is we're
blessed with amazing chefs
in our kitchens
here, but we also
have the luxury of
microkitchens all over Google.
The other day, I grabbed a bar.
It's delicious.
I finished it.
And then I realized it was
made from cricket protein.
It was called Eat Grub.
I don't know if you're
familiar with it.
I'd really be interested
in your thoughts on the--
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
The world of eating insects.
AUDIENCE: The world
of eating insects.
If you've experimented with it.
And if so, how do you see that
evolving into everyday kitchen?
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
I think
it's going to be
massive and important.
It's a really good
source of protein.
Of course, we've
eaten insects forever.
Ever since we could
call ourselves
any sort of a human being,
we've been insect eaters.
It's only in quite
evolved Western cultures
where it's considered
odd to eat insects.
So again, potentially,
insects could
be a great source of sustainable
food, sustainable protein.
And not necessarily
exotic either.
I have experimented
a little bit,
but I'm only just
sort of starting
to get my head around it.
And I think it's
going to be massive.
But mealworms, which you
can easily grow at home,
using actually little bits of--
talking about
leftover vegetables
when they really are past
their prime-- mealworms,
you just have a few little
carrot peelings or little bits
you sprinkle them over the top
of the bran that they live in.
You've got these
little black beetles,
and they produce these
wriggly little mealworms.
I don't know if anyone's
familiar with them.
If you feed birds
in your garden,
you might have bought
dried mealworms.
But with this, this is a
really useful ingredient.
Quite a simple,
unoffensive taste to it.
People make mealworm
cookies now,
which I've tried,
which are pretty good.
We've had some enthusiastic
insects businesses
come and talk and sell their
food at River Cottage Festival.
So definitely something not to
be seen as purely eccentric.
It's going to be
highly relevant to some
of the big issues we talked
about at the beginning
of this session.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
Hi.
I'm Shaz.
This is Yogi.
Sorry.
He gets a little
bit [INAUDIBLE]..
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
Hi, Yogi and Shaz.
AUDIENCE: So firstly,
I want to thank
you so much for coming in.
I was so excited
about your talk.
I actually cleared my
calendar for today.
So I just wanted to ask
a couple of questions.
I saw a program of yours
quite while ago about you
doing a vegan or a
vegetarian wedding.
I don't know if you recall that?
HUGH
FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So I'm getting
married next year.
And sort of unlike
traditional weddings
where you have to request
a vegetarian meal,
I would actually love to do
it all vegetarian, flirting
with the idea of veganism.
And if you really need
meat, you can request it.
I have actually had a few
wedding planners laugh
in my face already about that.
So a couple of
questions on that.
One, have you done a
second vegan or vegetarian
wedding since then?
Two, what is sort of
the general feeling
that you get from
the guests on that?
And three, who do I
nee to talk to to hire
you to do my wedding?
[LAUGHTER]
Please.
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
Have we
done a completely vegetarian
wedding since then?
I'm not quite sure,
but we've certainly
done some big vegetarian nights
and big vegetarian events.
Ben, who's here somewhere,
might know whether we've
done any more veggie weddings.
Not completely.
And in fact, I understand there
might be a few tickets left
if anybody is interested.
We're doing a big
vegan feast based
on the recipes from this book at
Borough Market tomorrow night.
It's a fundraiser for the
Borough Market Traders Fund
for traders who were affected
by the terror attacks
back in June.
So I love doing all
vegetarian or vegan events.
And I've just had another
one come in into my inbox
a couple of days ago.
Born Free, the charity, the
wildlife conservation charity,
want to do a vegetarian banquet,
and I'm putting a menu together
for that.
I love it absolutely
it, and so do my team.
And Ben and I work
together, Gil and I
and Gelf, who's now the
head chef at River Cottage.
All the River
Cottage canteens are
very big on veg we have a whole
section of the menu called
Veg Out, which is 10 to a
dozen vegetable side dishes
but always with a little
extra twist or with something
added, whether it's
some seeds or a spice
or a particular way
of cooking things,
As well as loads of
vegetarian options right
through the rest of the menu.
So I take vegetarian and vegan
food very, very seriously.
And I think putting it at
the center of a celebration
is absolutely no problem.
I went to my goddaughter's
21st-birthday party
last weekend.
And she decided to have
a vegetarian feast,
and it was absolutely delicious.
So yeah, lots you can do.
And don't let your
friends talk you out of it
if that's the way
you want to go.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
Thanks a lot.
And if anyone else wants
to come tomorrow night,
if you haven't got
a golden ticket,
it's a massively good cause.
It's going to be an
amazing vegetable feast.
It is 120 quid a
ticket, but that
is making a substantial donation
to this amazing fund that's
helping put Borough
Market back on its feet.
So if you were interested,
Josie, somewhere here--
where?
Oh, she's just outside.
Josie from River Cottage can
talk to you more about that.
MARIANA SARACENI: By the way,
if you auction the tickets,
you can donate that
money to the cause.
Just so you know, guys, we're
running a bit late on time.
So if you have any super-long
questions, maybe for after.
But short, come on in.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm Neri.
Thank you so much for your talk.
It was really,
really interesting.
I have my own vegan
Indian food blog,
and I'm really into creating
sort of Indian recipes.
But I sort of find
it quite difficult
with some other
cuisines to really find
things which are, as you
say, very veg-focused
and really bring out vegetables.
It's kind of contrary
to a question asked
before where you were like,
which cuisine inspires you
the most, but are
there any cuisines
you found which are really
difficult to create veg
recipes from but that
you've kind of managed
to find inspiration from?
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
Any areas
that are difficult to create?
AUDIENCE: Any cuisines
which are not veg-focused?
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
I think
sort of Central European cooking
and old school British-English
cooking is not massively
adventurous with veg.
We have to face up to that.
And as soon as you get around
to other parts of the world--
I mean, I suppose it's
partly a climate thing,
but I don't think that's a
good enough excuse for us
because we know
that in this country
we can grow
wonderful vegetables.
But it's also a
cultural thing where
to be putting meat
on the table seemed
like a kind of priority,
a kind of way of saying,
we're doing OK.
Look, we've got meat every day.
And I think that's what
drove a lot of the idea
that everyone could have
a chicken in the oven
every weekend.
That's one thing.
But a chicken in a
sandwich every day
or a piece of fried
chicken in a bun every day,
that's led to industrial
farming, and that's
a whole different thing.
But I think that the tropical
cuisines of the world
and also, often, the peasant
are much more resourceful
with vegetables.
And so all over Asia,
but also South America,
you've got great traditions
of using things like beans
and rice as the essential
food and then jazzing them up
with all kinds of
delicious vegetables
and fruit and spices
and nuts coming into it.
But, I mean, we should all
have that vernacular now.
And I'm sure there's all kinds
of influences in those recipes
which I could start
to deconstruct,
but I wouldn't even
be conscious of them
when I put the recipe together.
But definitely, a lot of Indian
and Asian in there, and I
guess some Mexican
and South American
stuff, a lot of good ideas
around veg come from there.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MARIANA SARACENI: Go for it.
If it's quick, you can come in.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thank you.
Nice to meet you.
Thank you very
much for your time.
We've seen the advent of
the impossible burger.
And given that agribusinesses is
the single largest contributor
to greenhouse gases
on the planet--
so basically it's warming the
planet through cows farting--
with the advent of the
impossible burger and meat
being made from plants,
what's your take
or how does this kind
of resonate with you?
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
Look.
I mean, creating meat-like
textures from plants
probably is not a bad idea
because so many people are
attached to those
consistencies and flavors.
I haven't done the taste test
for that so-called thing.
I don't think it's
necessarily central.
I think really being
much more relaxed
without denaturing them
or reconstructing them
or growing strange
things in laboratories,
vegetables already offer
us a massive solution
to the problems of
global agriculture.
But the thing we
mustn't forget--
and it's so easy to-- is that
ultimately it is our choice.
And I get that huge
amounts of money
are spent on us making
the choices that industry
wants to make.
And that's not like some
big sinister conspiracy.
That's just capitalism.
That's just the drive
of making money.
And it's all about margins
and people have found out,
as I said at the beginning, that
cheap starch, fat, and sugar--
all highly-refined fats
and carbohydrates--
can be whizzed into
any number of things.
Somehow, we have to
push back against that
by knowing what's really good
for us and for the planet
and making the choices that
are going to make a difference.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
Thank you very much.
MARIANA SARACENI:
Our last question
because we are
five minutes over.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Hugh.
I'm Alex.
I have a question
about children.
You started talking
about it earlier.
So I cook in my house, and my
wife used to be a vegetarian.
So I used to cook pretty much
three meals-- kids' meals,
my wife's meal, and my meal.
I mean, I would love
all of these things,
and I think my kids would
definitely like some of them.
But there are, as you
said, some complex flavors
and spices in here.
How best can I get my
children-- who are young,
two and a half and five--
to start adventuring
more with their food
and getting more sophisticated
palates at that kind of age?
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
It's a really good question.
Putting a lot of
stuff in front of kids
early is really important--
really early.
I mean, I'm not saying
you're too late,
but there is something that
kicks in with kids, which
is that after a certain age--
and it's usually the age when
they're independently mobile--
they become a bit
mistrustful of new foods.
And there's an
evolutionary reason
for that, which is that,
once you wander away
from the immediate control of
your parent figure, usually
your mother, you don't want to
be popping berries and things
randomly into your mouth.
So a little bit of
protection kicks in.
So you need to
encourage your children
to recognize as many
different foods as possible
are safe and exciting.
Even if they don't necessarily
like them straightaway,
it's important that they
know that they are food.
And there's all sorts of
things I didn't like as a kid
that I've somehow
come around to.
Mushrooms, ugh, slimy,
revolting things.
Now, I love them to bits.
Tomatoes, couldn't go near
one, mainly because they used
to be completely tasteless.
Although I was addicted
to tomato ketchup,
so there was kind of
a contradiction there.
But it's about variety.
It's about using spices
in a very subtle way
to begin with because
kids actually do quite
like a little bit of spice.
Kids love garlic.
A little bit of garlicky oil.
Green beans and carrots
plainly steamed, fine.
But if you cook a tiny
bit of garlic in oil
or a little bit
of butter and you
toss the vegetables in that,
that little savory edge
makes it--
there's something for
them to catch onto there
that they often really like.
So a little bit of
seasoning, not too much salt.
Also, it's a bit of an easy
win salt. Kids do like salt,
so you have to be a bit careful.
But tiny bits of garlic,
very, very small amounts
of curry powder
even can actually
stimulate kids to
like vegetables
more rather than less.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
Thanks a lot.
MARIANA SARACENI: Hugh,
can you stick around
for signing a few cookbooks
and any questions?
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
I would love to.
Anyone who wants to come over
and say hi and get a book
signed, I'd be
absolutely delighted.
MARIANA SARACENI: Thank
you, everyone, for coming.
Thank you, Hugh.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGH FEARNLEY-WHITTINGSTALL:
Thank you all.
Thank you very much.